more and more games are being built in
unreal engine 5 right now the latest
version of epic games popular game
development software ranging from
licensed mobile titles to
aaa blockbusters and we've gathered up
all the games that are using it
in a surprising turn of events cd
projekt red has announced a brand new
witcher game that will be built entirely
in unreal 5 instead of the company's
internal red engine that the team used
for the previous witcher games the
polish studio will collaborate with
epic's engineers to help make unreal
engine 5 the best engine it can be for
open world games with experience and
knowledge from the development process
informing the evolution of unreal 5 for
future projects not much else is known
about the game right now but we're very
excited nonetheless
you know what i've always said about
studio wild card sequel to the popular
survival sandbox arc it's that it's all
about family and arc 2 which is in
development right now is certainly
taking that to heart arc 2 is utilizing
unreal 5 for its eventual and exclusive
release on xbox series x and s the
multiplayer game will star fast and
furious actor vin diesel as the hero
santiago with the hollywood actor
pulling a double shift as an executive
producer on the game as well it's just a
shame they couldn't pull in dwayne turok
johnson as well i'm sorry
ashes of creation developer intrepid
studios confirmed a few months ago that
it had migrated the game from unreal 4
to unreal 5. it's still early days for a
project that is still in its alpha phase
but the studio has been incredibly
transparent with fans of the upcoming
game as to why and how they're making
the change to unreal 5 and the impact it
will have on the game when it eventually
launches
it'll still be a while before a new game
in the gears of war series is properly
unveiled but for now developer the
coalition appears to have a firm grip on
using unreal 5 to create the title
during a presentation at gdc 2021 the
coalition revealed its first technical
demo alpha point using the latest tools
in unreal engine 5 which included
application of the lumen lighting system
and nanite the engine's virtualized
geometry system in addition to that the
studio also showed off a character
render demo within unreal engine 5 that
was packed with all manner of small
details but after the cliffhanger at the
end of gears 5 we really hope we don't
have to wait too long
revealed back in 2020 black myth wukong
is easily one of the most exciting
adaptations of the classic journey to
the west novel since enslaved brimming
with action and adventure unreal 5 has
been used to deliver intense boss
battles and impressive particle effects
the dark souls inspired game from
developer game science doesn't have a
confirmed release date yet but
everything they've released so far is
looking pretty pretty good
while there wasn't much in the way of
concrete details when dragon quest 12
the flames of fate was announced in 2021
square enix did confirm that the next
chapter in the beloved long-running rpg
series would be shaking up the franchise
with unreal 5 powering a darker tale of
swords and sorcery dragon quest 12
series creator yuji hori hinted at
darker themes more open-ended design and
impactful decisions that the player will
be forced to make
not much is known about the new tomb
raider game other than it's being made
by crystal dynamics and it will run on
unreal engine 5. work on the new tomb
raider has only just started according
to the developer during epic's state of
unreal briefing after which they added
our goal is to push the envelope of
fidelity and to deliver the high quality
cinematic action adventure experience
that fans deserve from both crystal
dynamics and the tomb raider franchise
while unreal 5 is expected to be capable
of creating epic and detailed worlds for
games the technology is also being used
for titles with a cozier appeal take
dream house for example a house
construction simulator coming to pc and
console in the future using unreal 5
you'll be able to build sturdy
structures set up comfortable living
spaces and eventually call it a day on
next-gen beds unreal 5 is more than
capable of creating impressive particle
effects and lifelike human characters
but a thread count you can see on gaming
linen that's what really counts you can
also explore your creations in vr if you
really want to get that grand designs
experience
echoes of the end is described as a
single-player rpg from icelandic
developer mirka games and takes place in
a world of myth and legend as the hero
rin it'll be up to you to guide the
warrior through large-scale battles in a
world that has been described as a blend
of cinematic scope and rich narrative
themes all realized with unreal 5
technology
you might not have heard of this hidden
gem who am i kidding it's one of the
biggest games in the world epic
signature game fortnite made a shift to
unreal engine 5 with the start of
chapter 3 back in december 2021 while
the changes seen so far look like modest
upgrades expect the overall visual
fidelity to steadily increase as time
goes on as epic improves on its unreal 5
technology small changes eventually add
up to something big and fortnite will
likely continue to be a showcase for the
versatility of epic software
currently in development at net marble
very little is known about this mobile
game of thrones adaptation other than
its usage of unreal 5 for development
netmarble has a history of producing
solid adaptations of licensed properties
including marvel for mobile devices and
the studio revealed that it planned to
deliver console level graphics while
telling an original story in the fantasy
world created by author george r.r
martin let's hope the game ends better
than the show did
with a focus on mystery exploration and
stomach churning monster designs team
clout's ill is using unreal 5 to create
a disturbing and spooky atmosphere the
devil is in the details and while not
much else is known about this survival
horror game early previews indicate that
epic's technology is being used to
create a uniquely terrifying experience
a sequel to the legend of mere series
korean developer we made entertainment
is making use of epic's biggest unreal 5
technologies meta human creator lumen
and nanite to craft this mmorpg
platforms and a release window have yet
to be announced but like mere 4 you can
expect nft implementation that allows
for your game character to be turned
into a token for selling and trading if
that's your thing
coming to pc and xbox series xns at some
point in the future hopefully sooner
rather than later arcane's red fall is
an action adventure that uses unreal 5
to craft a vampire hunting experience
playable in solo or co-op modes details
and gameplay footage has been hard to
come by since redfall was announced at
microsoft's e3 2021 showcase if a recent
leak turns out to be genuine though
expect this game to use epic software to
create a vibrant environment with loot
shooter mechanics also did i mention the
vampires
developer ninja theory has occasionally
released some development information
since senua's saga hellblade 2 was
confirmed to be in development and with
unreal 5 powering the sequel to the
original hellblade game it's shaping up
to look like a visual showcase for the
technology the first gameplay trailer
was shown off at last year's game awards
while development has used quite a few
strange techniques to get the game
looking just right
another horror game utilizing unreal 5
quantum era uses the technology to
create stylish graphics and a terrifying
atmosphere it's the lighting that really
sells the nightmarish visuals though and
with unreal 5 capable of creating
realistic and spooky illumination
quantum era's handle on horror looks
immersive and eerie
a free showcase of the potential of
unreal 5 developed by epic the matrix
awakens is a stunning showcase of
playable action and exploration it's
available to try out now on pc xbox
series xns and ps5 and offers not only a
brief highway chase scene that looks
like it was ripped straight out of the
matrix reloaded but also a detailed
breakdown of the various technologies
within unreal 5 and how they're used to
create photorealistic environments
paint and paranoia take the center stage
in this return to layers of fear details
on the next installment are vague but
with unreal 5's ability to create
realistic textures and unsettling
environments the end result could be a
detailed dip into horror from a studio
that has earned a reputation for being a
master of that genre
described as a unique time travel mmorpg
from developer etlox studios development
on the game has been rocky as of late
due to russia's invasion of ukraine a
new pre-alpha session was held recently
and if you'd like to see how unreal 5 is
shaping the visual development of this
ambitious game you can check out an
official teaser but into the echo that
showcases some rich visuals
founded by starcraft 2 production
director tim morton and warcraft 3 the
frozen throne lead campaign designer tim
campbell frost giant's first game has
been teased as a dream project that
won't simply be a throwback to classic
real-time strategy the studio has kept
details under wraps for its
in-development game but it has let slip
that it'll be developing the rts on
unreal 5 and that it's designed to be
more approachable for newcomers to the
genre
midnight society is a new studio
featuring the talent of a number of
famous faces including dr disrespect
and call of duty's robert bowling their
mission statement is to put the audience
first when creating quote the most
rewarding gaming experiences possible
and their new game currently titled
project moon will be using unreal engine
5 to hopefully do all that
mortal online 2 recently launched into
beta after being in steam early access
it's a huge fantasy first person mmorpg
that lets you explore a huge sandbox as
well as shape your character's build the
way you want it to be the game studio
was recently awarded an epic mega grant
and will be transferring the game
eventually from unreal 4 to 5.
stalker 2 has been a long-awaited sequel
but obviously with the russian invasion
of ukraine still ongoing plans to
release the title later this year have
obviously been upended as developer gsc
gameworld looks to find safety and
shelter for its staff what we know about
the game so far is that it's using
unreal 5 to create a uniquely unsettling
atmosphere one that's dripping with
grime and radioactive fallout
so there you have it every unreal engine
5 game that we know of so far we can't
wait to see how these games end up
looking and playing and let me know in
the comments which one you're most
looking forward to for me it definitely
has to be another witcher you can find
me on twitter at lucy james games and
we'll catch you next time
[Music]